[Musik]
meditation gut insbesondere sogenannte
achtsamkeit kurse erfreuen sich auch in
der schweiz wachsender beliebtheit nicht
nur einzelne buchen diese kurse sondern
auch universitäten sports verbände
unternehmen und schulen üben sich
neuerdings in achtsamkeit kein wunder
denn entsprechende wissenschaftliche
studien sollen beweisen dass uns
regelmäßiges meditieren
stressresistenter und sogar mit vielen
der nacht einer der es nicht ganz so
positiv sieht ist der britische
historiker theodor zerlin er sagt
mitgefühl trainieren wir indem wir
anderen menschen helfen und nicht indem
wir uns aufs meditations- kisten setzen
ihn treffe ich später in zürich zum
gespräch doch zuerst spreche ich mit
richards davidson der
neurowissenschaftler ist einer der
führenden experten wenn es um die frage
geht welche auswirkungen meditation auf
unsere hirn und unsere gesundheit hat er
ist im moment zu gast auf dem landgut in
der nähe von bern wo er seine
forschungsresultate präsentiert hier
sind wir zu gast ich freue mich auf's
gespräche stattfinden sie sind professor
für psychologie und psychiatrie an der
universität madison wisconsin sie sind
ein sehr gefragter mann sie haben es
auch schon auf die liste der 100
einflussreichsten persönlichkeiten des
time magazine geschafft ich freue mich
sehr dass sie zeit haben für uns so toll
was freut mich hier zu seinen vielen
dank meditation ist ein riesiger buben
glauben sie dass hier irgendwann alle
meditieren
ich glaube eines tages wird man die
mentalen training den gleichen
stellenwert beimessen wie heute der
körperlichen fitness ab in den meisten
westlichen ländern weiß man inzwischen
dass körperliche betätigung gesund ist
und viele nehmen sich jede woche zeit
dafür
ich denke man wird irgendwann mentale
übungen leichte meditations- formen so
häufig absolvieren wie körperliches
training sobald man merkt wie wichtig
dies für unseren geist und unser gehirn
ist
es gibt ganz unterschiedliche formen der
meditation sie sagen auch so wie es
unterschiedliche sportarten gibt gibt es
auch unterschiedliche meditationsform
bei uns ist es vor allem die achtsamkeit
meditation die sich großer beliebtheit
erfreut sie wurde vor allem von jon
kabat zinn weiterentwickelt und
sozusagen populär gemacht und schon
karmazin war auch bei uns in den
sternstunde philosophie zu gast vor zwei
jahren schauen wir kurz gemeinsam zurück
entwickelt hat die achtsamkeit
meditation der us amerikaner jon kabat
zinn ende der 70er jahre seine absicht
wahr als östliche 10 meditation und yoga
mit westlicher medizin zu verbinden
meditation im westen einzuführen das
klang 1979 völlig verrückt als wäre ich
ein bekiffter hippie der das
gesundheitssystem missbrauchen doch dann
bekam der vermeintliche guru
schützenhilfe von der wissenschaft der
neuropsychologe ritscher davidson begann
die auswirkungen von meditation auf das
gehirn zu erforschen mit spektakulären
resultaten
2004 zeigte er in einer studie mit
buddhistischen mönchen das regelmäßige
meditation die hirnströme verändert
sobald die wissenschaft anfing sich
damit zu befassen
ich begann damit 1979 wurde es sehr
schwierig zu behaupten dass meditation
nichts bringe doch nun hatten wir nicht
mehr bloß die anekdotischen nachweise
von zahlreichen patienten mit vielen
unterschiedlichen chronischen diagnosen
sondern auch die wissenschaftlichen
objektiveren resultate
sie zeigten dass meditation die
physiologie sowie die architektur und
struktur ihres gehirns wirklich
verändert die anzahl der studien zum
thema ist seither förmlich explodiert
in vielen konnten positive effekte auf
den organismus und das gehirn
nachgewiesen werden
bei probanden die regelmäßig meditieren
stellte man im gehirn veränderungen in
regionen fest die für erinnerungen
körperbewusstsein oder den umgang mit
emotionen zentral sind sie sind ein
pionier wenn es darum geht die
auswirkungen der meditation auf gehirn
und geist und gesundheit zu erforschen
sie haben ein neues buch vorgelegt out
trades und in diesem buch sagen sie aber
auch wir müssen endlich den bremsen was
die erwartungen anbelangt ich würde
gerne von ihnen wissen welche resultate
sind dann wirklich gesichert
das ist eine sehr wichtige frage und wie
sie erwähnt haben untersuchte ich in
diesem buch zusammen mit dem psychologen
daniel goleman die wichtigsten
forschungsergebnisse im bereich der
meditation
das buch heißt auf englisch ortet trades
damit verweisen wir auf die
langfristigen veränderungen durch die
meditationspraxis wie sich
herausgestellt hat gibt es nur wenige
wissenschaftlich anerkannte
untersuchungen die belegen dass
meditieren das gehirn tatsächlich
langfristig verändert aber wir haben
immerhin fundierte forschungsergebnisse
für verschiedene bereiche gefunden zum
beispiel bezüglich der aufmerksamkeit
es steht außer frage dass wir wie der
psychologe william james 1890 sagte
unsere aufmerksamkeit schulen können wir
können lernen unsere
konzentrationsfähigkeit zu verbessern
und unseren zerstreuten geist zu
bändigen
mit etwas training kriegen wir das hin
und gewisse hirnareale werden durch die
meditationspraxis tatsächlich verändert
wie die forschung zeigt braucht es dafür
gar nicht so viel schon nach zwanzig
oder dreißig meditation stunden lassen
sich veränderungen im gehirn nach
das heißt nicht dass diese dauerhaft
sind aber dass sie schon nach kurzer
zeit eintreten können
es braucht hingegen mehr praxis bis aus
den veränderungen so etwas wie eine
bleibende neue grundstruktur wird eine
der wichtigen ideen ist da die
sogenannte neuroplastizität also die
vorstellung dass auch das gehirn
wirklich formbar ist wie sie jetzt
gesagt haben wenn man lange meditiert
auch nachhaltig veränderbar ist sie
sagen an einer stelle im buch auch es
gibt so etwas wie mental
also ein fitnessstudio fürs gehirn muss
ich mir wirklich das hirn so vorstellen
wie einen muskel den ich formen kann die
ich möchte nun ich sage oft das
neuroplastizität sowohl bewusst als auch
unbewusst funktioniert meistens wird
unser gehirn durch äußere kräfte geformt
auf die wir wenig einfluss haben
und derer wir uns meist nicht bewusst
sind mit unserem buchladen wir daher die
leser ein mehr verantwortung für ihr
hirn zu übernehmen
wir können unser gehirn selber formen in
dem wir positive und gesunde geistes
gewohnheiten trainieren die sich zeigt
verändert sich das gehirn durch
entsprechende mentale übungen und zwar
zum besseren
und diese veränderungen im gehirn
schaffen wiederum eine grundlage für
langfristige veränderungen in unserem
erleben und verhalten
wir können verantwortung übernehmen
wir übernehmen verantwortung für uns ja
aber auf die gleiche weise wie wir
verantwortung für unseren körper
übernehmen wenn wir sport treiben oder
mehrmals täglich unsere zähne putzen
wir wissen dass diese persönliche
körperhygiene wichtig ist wenn uns also
bewusst wird wie kostbar unser gehirn
unser geist ist in bezug auf das was uns
als menschen ausmacht kümmern wir uns um
unser gehirn gleich sorgsam wie um
unsere zähne und unseren körper
daher lautet unsere botschaft meditation
ist etwas einfaches und eine zwingende
gesundheitliche notwendigkeit für uns
alle sagen sie in diesem buch ja auch
die erwartungen sind extrem artikel
geschrieben
gesagt wird meditation verändert das
leben umfassend und eben nicht nur jetzt
die haben das schon gesagt unsere art
und weise die aufmerksam wir sind
sondern auch solche dinge wie
beispielsweise schmerzverarbeitung wer
regelmäßig meditiert empfindet zwar auch
schmerz aber erholt sich schneller davon
aber auch zb jetzt gesagt die telomere
verändern sich und die telomere sind
verantwortlich für das die art und weise
wie wir altern kann die mir darf genau
erklären stinkt doch sicher gehen wir
zuerst nochmals einen schritt zurück mit
alldem befasst sich die
wissenschaftliche forschung
es kursieren viele behauptungen
bezüglich der vorteile von meditation
vor allem in den medien
und es ist wichtig einige dieser
behauptungen mit vorsicht zu genießen
wir können zb nicht alle unsere
krankheiten durch meditation heilen
dafür wurde sie auch gar nicht
entwickelt aber nehmen wir die telomere
nach denen sie mich gefragt haben
telomere sind biologische merkmale
unseres alterungsprozess wir alle werden
älter
das gehört zu unserer natürlichen
biologischen veranlagung aber die frage
ist wie schnell wir altern
bei gewissen menschen erfolgt die
abnutzung der molekularen maschinerie
sehr rasch bei anderen eher langsam
laut gewissen forschungsergebnissen kann
meditation diesen alterungsprozess
verlangsamen
sie kann die alterung nicht rückgängig
machen verlangsamt aber den verkürzung
prozess der telomere ein richtiger
pionier auf diesem gebiet und eine
unglaublich wichtige fachpersonen als
sie damit angefangen haben 1970 wollten
sie schon ihre doktorarbeit zum thema
meditation schreiben da haben alle
gesagt vergessen sie ist das ist das
ende ihrer karriere um sie beschreiben
in einem buch auch und sagen in
verschiedenen interviews es war
eigentlich die begegnung mit dem dalai
lama die damals für sie deutlich gemacht
hat doch ich versuche es trotzdem und
dann sind sie diesen weg gegangen heute
sind die sehr erfolgreich damit wie kam
es denn überhaupt dazu dass sie den
dalai lama getroffen haben
dem dalai lama begegnete ich 1992 zum
ersten mal
[Musik]
er bat mich und andere wissenschaftler
mögliche veränderungen im gehirn von
menschen mit langjähriger
meditationspraxis zu erforschen
er ermutigte mich die mittel der
modernen neurowissenschaften einzusetzen
um qualitäten wie güte und mitgefühl im
gehirn nachzuweisen
anstatt nur die negativen auswirkungen
des lebens zu erforschen
denn bis zu dem punkt hatte ich mich nur
mit stress not angst und depressionen
befasst
er fragte mich warum können sie ihre
messmethoden nicht einsetzen um auch
positive gefühle zu untersuchen
das hat mich wachgerüttelt
ich lernte ihn also 1992 kennen
damals begann unsere beziehung
inzwischen treffe ich ihn zwei drei mal
pro jahr wenige jahre nach unserer
ersten begegnung besuchte ich ihn in
seiner residenz im indischen dharamsala
da fasste er mich am arm und bat mich
auf seine direkte weise ich möchte dass
sie unsere meditationspraxis in eine
weltliche technik umwandeln und sie im
labor mit den strengsten
wissenschaftlichen methoden auf ihre
wirksamkeit hin testen wenn sie
herausfinden dass unsere art der
meditation nützlich ist verbreiten sie
sie weltweit und genau das wurde zur
aufgabe meines restlichen lebens
das mmi gerät gesteckt haben sie haben
sozusagen gehe ich die gehirne von
meditierenden münchen untersucht und sie
unterscheide in diesen neuen buch alter
trades auch zwei wege der meditation sie
sagen es gibt den tiefen weg und es gibt
den weiten weg und die tiefen die in den
tiefen weg gehen die eben sehr intensiv
täglich meditieren über viele viele
jahre hinweg die zeigen eben
hirnveränderungen die nicht einfach so
wieder weggehen sondern die wirklich
physiologisch messbar sind
ich habe mir dann die zahlen angeguckt
und dann habe ich gedacht okay da muss
man wirklich die erlanger meditieren sie
nennen 27.000 stunden die diese yogis
oder diese mönche meditiert haben das
entspricht ungefähr ein bisschen mehr
als drei jahre volle lebenszeit
das ist vielleicht für einen anfänger
ein bisschen frustrierend was ist mit
einer person die sagen wir mal drei mal
die woche zehn minuten meditiert
verändert das auch schon etwas ja das
ist eine äußerst wichtige frage das
nehmen wir sehr ernst
als wir mit unserer arbeit vergangen
konzentrierten wir uns auf mönche mit
langjähriger meditations- erfahrung
sollten wir keine veränderungen in ihrem
gehirn feststellen würden wir auch
nichts finden im gehirn von menschen die
weniger intensiv meditieren
[Musik]
deshalb wollten wir mit diesen experten
beginnen und wir fanden tatsächlich
veränderungen
das ermutigte uns die gehirne von
menschen mit weniger meditations-
erfahrung zu untersuchen
mit anfängern können wir präzisere
forschung betreiben
denn wir können nach dem zufallsprinzip
ausgewählte testpersonen anweisen zu
meditieren und sie mit personen
vergleichen die nicht meditieren
in diesen streng kontrollierten studien
haben wir dokumentiert dass man schon
nach sieben stunden meditation
veränderungen im gehirn nachweisen kann
immer mal wieder zwei minuten feiern
oder gibt es auch eine mindestdauer die
man dranbleiben muss profession
das ist eine sehr gute frage
und meine ehrliche antwort ist wir
wissen es nicht
wahrscheinlich ist das von mensch zu
mensch verschieden angenommen sie wollen
täglich 30 minuten meditieren ist es
besser diese am stück zu tun oder drei
mal zehn minuten beziehungsweise zehn
mal drei minuten zu meditieren wir
wissen es schlichtweg nicht
und wenn man jetzt gesetzt den fall man
könnte eines tages mit keine ahnung
irgendwelchen elektronischen stimuli das
hirn und einen punkt bringen indem es
diese 27.000 stunden meditation einfach
so geschenkt kriegt würden sie das
bedauern denken sie es ist wichtig
diesen weg zu gehen oder denken sie nein
eigentlich ist das ziel einfach von
ihren zu haben
[Musik]
wenn man durch neurostimulation
tatsächlich dieselben veränderungen im
gehirn bewirken könnte wie durch
langjährige meditation man also auf
diese weise schnell das gleiche resultat
erzielen würde
warum nicht ich bin jedoch höchst
skeptisch als neurowissenschaftler finde
ich es anmaßend zu behaupten wir wüssten
genug über die veränderbarkeit des
gehirns um solche veränderungen durch
neurostimulation herbeiführen zu können
ich bin ziemlich sicher dass dies
heutzutage nicht möglich ist
das gegenteil zu behaupten wäre
scharlatanerie denn es stimmt nicht die
veränderungen des gehirns sind zu
komplex zu kompliziert im moment gibt es
keinen ersatz zur meditationspraxis der
dalai lama sagte uns einmal im scherz
wenn sie eine pille entwickeln könnten
die mein mitgefühl unendlich steigert
oder wenn sie durch eine operation mein
gehirn so verändern könnten dass ich
mitfühlender würde wäre ich sofort dabei
ich verstehe absolut dass ihre skepsis
vor allem eine wissenschaftlich ist und
die ist wahrscheinlich auch wirklich
berechtigt so wie sie es beschreiben
ich habe gedacht vielleicht gibt es aber
auch noch eine skepsis die vielleicht
mehr spiritueller ort ist es ist ja so
dass diese ganze achtsamkeit meditation
kommt aus der übersetzung des passwortes
saatchi & saatchi ist nur ein teil
dieses so genannten edlen achtfachen
pfades und da würde man ja denken na ja
und meditation ist ein teil eines ganzen
spirituellen prozesses und da kann man
nicht eben mit einem chip oder einer
kleinen stimulation verschiedene dinge
einfach überspringen sondern es geht
darum auch an sich zu arbeiten
würden sie das auch unterschreiben oder
denken sie auch lassen sie uns diese
spirituelle basis einfach mal
kurz beiseite schieben dem stimme ich zu
es gibt wichtige kriterien die man in
der klassischen meditations- literatur
findet welche die meditation in einen
weit größeren zusammenhang stellen
dahinter steht eine weltanschauung die
auf ethischen grundregeln beruht wenn
wir uns also auf ein kissen oder einen
stuhl setzen um zu meditieren
tun wir das nicht nur für uns selbst
viel mehr beruhigen wir unseren geist
und öffnen unser herz mehr zum nutzen
unserer mitmenschen als wir uns selber
diese altruistische motivation ist sehr
wichtig wahrscheinlich wichtiger als die
gewählte meditationstechnik das wurde
jedoch noch nicht erforscht daher
befassen wir uns momentan in unserem
zentrum damit dies sind wichtige
bereiche des spirituellen weges denen
wir mit wissenschaftlichen fragen auf
den grund gehen wollen
es gibt also noch viel mehr zu
erforschen als die frage der
meditationstechnik die bisher die
wissenschaftliche arbeit auf diesem
gebiet beherrscht hat es gibt ja auch
kritik an diesen unternehmen google sap
fords disney novartis was auch immer
denkt unternehmen die gratis kurse
anbieten in achtsamkeit für ihre
mitarbeitenden dass gesagt wird denen
geht es eben gar nicht darum mitgefühl
zu kultivieren oder die menschen
wirklich zu unterstützen auf ihrem weg
in ein glücklicheres leben sondern es
geht einfach darum sie stress
resistenter zu machen und dann wird auch
zum kite plötzlich so etwas wie eine
komplizin auf dem weg zu einem absolut
kalten wirtschaftssystem in dem jeder
einfach auf höchst
trainiert wird teilen sie diese kritik
oder haben sie da selber auch eine
befürchtung oder denken sie nein das
müssen wir nicht so eng sehen sie
sprechen einen wichtigen punkt an
während meiner arbeit in der
geschäftswelt bin ich den
unterschiedlichsten anwendungen von
achtsamkeit übungen und ähnlichen
praktiken begegnet einige gehören genau
in die von ihnen beschriebene kategorie
denn hinter diesem meditations-
angeboten erkannte ich die berechnende
und leicht manipulative absicht die
angestellten dadurch stress resistenter
und gefühliger für den geschäftsalltag
zu machen aber ich erlebte auch sie los
und firmenchefs mit einer völlig anderen
viel gesünderen einstellungen sie gehen
zum beispiel davon aus dass letztlich
alle profitieren wenn ihre angestellten
glücklich zur arbeit erscheinen
meditation hat einen positiven einfluss
auf deren arbeitseinstellung ist aber
ebenso gut für die ehepartner und ihr
übriges umfeld sie sind engagierter und
kündigen seltener
das bringt allen sehr viel es scheint
also eine win-win-situation zu sein
nun ich höre sehr oft dass leute dafür
keine zeit haben in unserem zentrum
arbeiten wir momentan an einem großen
projekt mit dem ziel mehr meditations-
angebote an
platz zu schaffen das ist teil der so
genannten health and mines initiative
unter anderem entwickeln wir eine
digitale plattform
es gibt aber auch noch andere bereiche
[Musik]
dabei ist uns etwas sehr wichtig wenn
jemand absolut keine zeit hat zu
meditieren und wie man ein der gedanke
sich zeit nehmen zu müssen für eine
entspannungstechnik schon stress
verursacht sagen wir sie müssen keine
einzige zusätzliche minute dafür
einsetzen
aber sie können trotzdem meditieren
wir zeigen ihnen wie es geht wir bieten
solche leute ein paar alltägliche
verrichtungen aufzuzählen die sie
intellektuell nicht fordern
die haben wir alle da ist der arbeitsweg
putzarbeiten der abwasch wäsche macht
was auch immer dann geben wir ihnen ein
paar einfache meditationsübungen die sie
sich anhören können während sie andere
dinge verrichten es ist meditieren beim
erledigen alltägliche verrichtungen es
geht vor allem um die haltung und die
qualität der achtsamkeit
denn wie einige meditationslehrer
beschrieben haben und ist der fokus auf
die achtsamkeit etwas fundamentales dass
alle meditationsform verbindet zu tun
hat ganz im moment auch zu sein sich auf
die schritte zu konzentrieren die vögel
zu hören
die pflanzen zu sehen zu riechen den
bärlauch beispielsweise jetzt im
frühling und dann habe ich plötzlich
mich dabei hat hopp nicht gedacht habe
vielleicht werden auch meine telomere
wieder ein bisschen länger
und dann war ich fast ein bisschen
enttäuschend habe gedacht ich schätze
die arbeit von herrn davidson sehr aber
ist es nicht auch schade denn ich dann
beginne dauernd daran zu denken was das
noch für zeiten fact haben könnte außer
dem umstand dass es einfach schön ist
ganz im moment zu sein
das ist eine sehr wichtige beobachtung
und ich würde ihnen empfehlen nehmen sie
es einfach wahr und nutzen sie es als
achtsamkeit übung alles kann nützlich
sein
nehmen sie wahr dass sie abgelenkt
werden vom gedanken das meditieren
nützlich sein könnte aber behandeln sie
diesen gedanken nicht anders als andere
gedanken
es sind nur gedanken das ist in ordnung
wichtig ist dass sie nicht daran hängen
bleiben der dalai lama hat mir erzählt
dass er manchmal beim meditieren
überlegt dass er dadurch sein gehirn
verändert das motiviert ihn daran ist
nichts falsch so lange man sich davon
nicht zu sehr aufhalten lässt
es ist ganz wichtig zu sehen dass
mitgefühl zu kultivieren ein ganz
wichtiger bestandteil dieser art der
meditation ist wenn ich an die situation
beispielsweise in syrien denke dann
frage ich mich wie können wir diese
situation verändern und ist das
beispielsweise etwas was sie auch
beschäftigt wie kriegen sie die
meditation in die politik rein will
ich denke um wirklich schwierige
konflikte auf der welt lösen zu können
müssen wir mit der jüngeren generation
beginnen die noch keine festgefahrenen
einstellungen hat gut belegte
forschungsergebnisse zeigen klar dass
jeder mensch mit einer neigung zu
warmherzigkeit sozialkompetenz und güte
geboren wird
das ist teil unserer menschlichen natur
wenn wir wählen können entscheiden wir
uns für kooperative soziale und humane
lösungen und reagieren nicht egoistisch
oder aggressiv schon bei kleinkindern
kann man diese tendenz beobachten
wenn wir also empfehlen zu meditieren um
mitgefühl zu kultivieren sagen wir nicht
man solle einen gemütszustand neu
erfinden sondern vielmehr eine qualität
erkennen und fördern die bereits
vorhanden ist
ähnlich wie bei der sprache jeder mensch
wird geboren mit der veranlagung sich
sprechend mitzuteilen
aber um diese fähigkeit zu entwickeln
müssen wir in einer gemeinschaft
aufwachsen die mittels sprache
kommuniziert in den seltenen fällen in
denen kinder in die regnitz aufwachsen
entwickeln sie keine normale
sprachfähigkeit wenn wir also mit der
jüngeren generation beginnen und diese
qualitäten in kleinkindern kultivieren
und stärken verbessern sich die chancen
für unsere welt markant deshalb
beinhaltet ein großer teil unserer
arbeit die bildung und früherziehung
unsere jüngste arbeit befasst sich sogar
mit vorgeburtlichen einflüssen die
sternstunde religion hat gerade vor
unserem gespräch ein film gezeigt mit
dem titel schule der achtsamkeit wo es
genau darum geht wie die achtsamkeit in
schulen einbinden können diese
meditationskurse für kinder vielleicht
ganz zum schluss sie haben am anfang
unseres gesprächs gesagt es geht nicht
nur darum unser hirn zu trainieren in
einem arzt mental jim unser gehirn zu
erweitern sondern es geht auch darum
negative einflüsse wegzulassen oder von
uns zu weisen
wovon sollten wir uns fernhalten herr
davidson
es geht nicht so sehr darum uns von
negativen einflüssen fernzuhalten
wir müssen vielmehr unsere beziehung
dazu verändern
unglücke passieren
niemand ist davor gefeit das leid gehört
zum menschsein
wir alle leiden das liegt in unserer
natur die frage ist daher wie gehen wir
damit um wie reagieren wir auf
schicksalsschläge eine wichtige
fähigkeit die man sich durch diese
meditations- praktiken aneignet ist
resilienz man lernt sich schneller zu
erholen
und das ist sehr wichtig für unser
wohlbefinden gern geschehen
meditation die welt verändern kann
den ich jetzt gleich in zürich treffe
ist da skeptisch der britische
historiker der lange zeit die
französische regierung und verschiedene
kommissionen der eu beraten hat sagt
meditation lenke den blick immer nach
innen dabei liege das große abenteuer
unserer zeit in der welt da draußen in
der begegnung mit anderen menschen
[Musik]
bei mir sitzt jetzt für berlin
emeritierter professor für geschichte an
der universität oxford und gefragter
berater von unternehmen und
regierungsorganisationen und er äußert
sich in interviews immer wieder kritisch
über den meditations- bogen was stört
sie daran wenn alle meditieren nicht
mehrmals
ich musste mich nur einmal kritisch und
es war in einem völlig anderen
zusammenhang
doch sofort stürzten sich die reporter
ist klar von dieser neuen therapie
darauf und veröffentlichten es geht mir
bei der meditation gleich wie bei
lebensmitteln
wenn sie zum beispiel gemüse kaufen
wollen sie wissen woher es kommt in was
für erde es gezogen wurde welche
pestizide dabei zur anwendung kam
das gleiche gilt für die meditation
was ist ihr ursprung in erster linie der
buddhismus
doch unsere meditations- formen haben
nichts mit buddhismus zu tun
ähnlich wie in unseren indischen
restaurants wo nicht indisches essen
serviert wird sondern eine westliche
version davon sind unsere
meditationsform und zugeschnitten auf
die westlichen kapitalisten auf all jene
die dafür bezahlen
zudem wurde die meditationspraxis von
den leuten die sie in der westlichen
welt einführten stark verändert
nur einen teil davon und zieht nicht die
ganze geschichte hinten dran aber ich
hatte schon den eindruck also das was
ich gelesen habe von ihrer kritik war
doch ein bisschen umfangreicher aus nur
einsatz
und da sagen sie beispielsweise
meditation lenke eigentlich vom denken
ab und das ist ja erst mal interessant
weil meditation will ja eigentlich
konzentration es nun lassen sie mich
fortfahren der ursprungsort der
meditation ist wie der von facebook die
harvard university
richard david daniel komen und alle
diese anderen wissenschaftler lernten
sich an der harvard university denn zur
gleichen zeit als ich dort gastdozent
war
sie waren damals studenten zu jener zeit
in den frühen 1970 ern gab es viele
verlorene seelen die in der hoffnung auf
erlösung nach indien reisten sie waren
begeistert denn was sie dort erlebten
war neu für sich und sie brachten es
nach hause
ausschlaggebend waren also die sorgen
der 1970 er jahre seither sind fast 50
jahre verstrichen und es hat sich sehr
vieles verändert wir haben uns von einer
industriegesellschaft zu einer
dienstleistungsgesellschaft entwickelt
die weltbevölkerung hat sich verdoppelt
wir haben neue sorgen wegen der umwelt
usw
daher sind die ideen des frühen
buddhismus nicht mehr auf unsere zeit
anwendbar
aber kommen wir noch einmal zum punkt
zurück der mich auch interessiert diese
idee dass meditation von denken ablenkt
was genau meinen sie damit also eine
these die sie in ihrem buch gut leben
ein kompass der lebenskunst vertreten
ist ja dass sie sagen denken ist anders
als viele leute meinen eine gesellige
aktivität die findet eben nicht nur zu
hause am bürotisch stadt oder auf den
meditations- kisten sondern es geht um
etwas geselliges lassen sie mich meine
erläuterungen zu ende führen
ich sage bei dieser meditationspraxis
geht ist darum sich auf sich selbst zu
konzentrieren
auf den eigenen atem auf den augenblick
für mich ist es keine
konzentrationsübung sondern etwas das
sie von allen anderen ablenkt es ist das
gegenteil von konzentration sich zu
konzentrieren heißt marie aspekte des
lebens zu betrachten und herauszufinden
wie sie miteinander zusammenhängt es ist
die fähigkeit botschaften zu empfangen
und im gehirn zu verarbeiten
[Musik]
nun gemäss kürzlich veröffentlichte
statistiken machen acht prozent der
us-amerikaner achtsamkeit übungen
weitere acht prozent konsumieren
beruhigungsmittel und antidepressiva
laut dieser studie können heute die
während fünf jahren medikamente wie
project konsumieren
diese danach nicht mehr absetzen bis
jetzt hat aber niemand erforscht ob die
leute die sich 20 jahre lang in
achtsamkeit löwen davon abhängig werden
ihren arten zu beobachten und im
augenblick präsent zu sein
grundsätzlich ist das sehr lobenswert
meditierende wollen ihren schmerz und
leid lindern was sehr gut ist
doch was können wir sonst tun wir können
unsere neugier dessen die großen denker
und künstler der vergangenheit haben die
welt betrachtet und gesagt unsere welt
ist anders als sie zu sein scheint wir
sollten sie entdecken anstatt uns zu
bemühen normal ruhig und zufrieden zu
sein
natürlich sind zufriedene bürger für
regierungen sehr angenehm
als cameron britischer premierminister
war investierte er geld in achtsamkeit
trainings denn er wollte zufriedene
bürger die sich nicht beschwerten und
keine revolution
und das waren die sehr interessant in
ihrem buch dass sie gesagt haben
eigentlich beginnen wir die
gesellschaftlichen probleme zu verlagern
auf die individuelle ebene also statt
dass wir politik betreiben legen wir uns
auf die couch und das kritisieren sie
das stimmt sie haben recht güte sagte
ich will mich nicht kennen
ich würde verrückt ich würde wegrennen
wenn ich mehr über mich wüsste zudem
kann man sich gar nicht den anteil ihrer
selbst hängt davon ab was andere über
sie denken
sie machen sich illusionen über sich
vielleicht noch einen punkt bei dieser
ganzen kritik an der meditations-
bewegung also offenbar kennen sie ja
wirklich die wurzeln auch sie haben am
anfang des gesprächs golden auch erwähnt
der sozusagen der erfinder ist der
emotionalen intelligenz der dieses buch
geschrieben hat
mit richards davidson zusammen über die
charakterzüge die imitation ausgebildet
werden
darüber habe ich eben gerade vorhin mit
richard davidson auch gesprochen und ein
stück weit sagen die beiden aber auch
ganz klar mit meditation können wir die
welt verändern und zwar deswegen weil
meditation uns nicht fühlen da macht
glauben sie auch dass nicht was mir in
allen werken dieser wissenschaftler
fehlt sie schreiben nichts über die welt
außer dass sie sie verändern wollen
doch wie weiß man wie die welt ist leute
wie davidson sind große bewunderer des
dalai lama dieses fallen mannes der
dinge sagt die den amerikanern sehr
gefahren er ist tatsächlich äußerst
charmant aber ein oberhaupt im exil
falls die täter frei und unabhängig
werden und er zurückkehrt kann er sein
amt als ihr oberhaupt ausüben obwohl das
inzwischen gar nicht mehr will
doch dann wird er zum politiker und
politiker haben kein einfaches leben
die beziehung zwischen religion und
machtpolitik ist seit jeher
spannungsgeladen und was fehlt in der
meditation ist das wissen um das was in
der welt passiert das kann man nur
herausfinden wenn man an die orte des
geschehens geht
mit verschiedenen menschen spricht und
erkennt dass alles so kompliziert ist
dass man die welt nicht endlich und da
sind wir glaube ich bei einem ganz
wichtigen punkt auch ihrer ich sage
jetzt trotzdem philosophie auch wenn sie
sagen sie sind kein philosoph sie haben
aber auch gesagt sie sind nicht wirklich
ein historiker obwohl sie ein
hochdekorierter historiker sind aber sie
haben am anfang als wir uns getroffen
haben gesagt ich bin in erster linie
jemand der in keine box gesteckt werden
will
ich behaupte sie jetzt trotzdem darauf
in ihrer philosophie sagen sie etwas was
wir lernen müssen ist richtig
miteinander zu sprechen statt meditieren
müssen wir gespräche führen
was genau ist die kunst des gesprächs
oder was kam das gespräch was die
meditation nicht sehen sie ursprünglich
sagte man sich in gesprächen was man
voneinander erwartete die meisten
menschen konnten sich nicht gut
ausdrücken
auch heute können das viele nicht
kürzlich machte ich eine entdeckung als
ich mit leuten sprach die kinder
unterstützen
sie erzählt mir dass sich diese kinder
in ihren familien nicht miteinander
unterhalten
sie sitzen vor dem fernseher oder
beschäftigen sich mit ihren smartphones
sie haben nicht gelernt miteinander zu
sprechen
das lernt man ihm zusammen sein mit
älteren familienangehörigen die
interessante dinge diskutieren frühere
wagten es viele nicht sich ins gespräch
einzubringen weil sie sich nicht gewählt
ausdrücken konnten
dass man dies lernt ist ein neues
phänomen und nur wenige können es wird
denn viele die von sich behaupten sie
könnten gespräche führen halten monologe
die politiker die nur sprechen und nicht
zu hören
wir müssen aber nicht die alte
gesprächskultur wieder entdecken sondern
eine neu erfinden den wänden yukon des
11 sie haben 2001 die oxford news
foundation gegründet und diese
foundation diese stiftung da geht es
eben darum dass sie einander
müssen sein können und dass wir wieder
lernen richtig gespräche zu führen war
gibt es gespräche diese organisieren
tisch runden wo man sich trifft mit den
unterschiedlichsten leuten bei der man
glaube ich zufällig zusammen gesetzt
was genau machen sie denn weiter so wie
lernt man den anderen banken aus anderen
menschen bei richtig gespräche zu führen
ich bringe niemandem etwas bei ich lasse
die leute von sich selber lernen
wichtig ist dass man weiß wovon man
spricht
viele menschen sprechen gern über sich
selber und das große problem für sie ist
dass sie niemanden finden der ihnen
zuhört
diese gelegenheit geben
ich heiße alle willkommen die dabei sein
wollen ich lade arbeitslose ein und
ehemalige häftlinge hatte aber auch
schon workshops mit den reichsten der
welt in der schweiz am
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos
ich mache begegnungen zwischen menschen
möglich die sich normalerweise nicht
treffen wird
so habe ich türkin eingeladen mit
armeniern zu sprechen obwohl sie diese
hassen
das funktioniert weil ich sie über dinge
sprechen lasse die ihnen wichtig sind
und was ist wichtig für sie die
beziehung zu ihren familien und freunden
ihre einsamkeit schwierigkeiten am
arbeitsplatz probleme mit ihren kindern
zutiefst menschliche dinge
ich gebe ihnen eine art mängelkarte wie
man sie im restaurant bekommt analog zur
aufteilung in fleisch und fischgerichte
und desserts leaste ich verschiedene
kategorien mit unterschiedlichen fragen
auf dieses buch das ich eben publiziert
habe enthält viele solche frage über die
man sich auch unterhalten kann
es sind allgemeine fragen die alle
betreffen ich vermeide politik
wirtschaft und solche dinge
die teilnehmer sollen nur über das reden
woran ihnen wirklich liegt und alle
mehr sie hätten bisher nie gelegenheit
dazu gehabt es geht ja schon auch darum
dass wir wirklich das privatleben in die
gespräche hinein bringen dass wir unsere
seelen sozusagen öffnen und im gespräch
das offenbaren vielleicht kann man so
metaphorisch sprechen und das scheint
ihnen wichtig zu sein
es passiert folgendes teilnehmer sagen
oder schreiben mir nach den workshops in
diesen gesprächen habe ich so viel über
mich gelernt wie über mein gegenüber
denn ich war gezwungen dinge zu erklären
die mir zuvor nicht klar waren an diesen
gesprächen nehmen leute aus allen
berufszweigen teil
manche finden am arbeitsplatz statt
damit sich die angestellten besser
kennen lernt andere organisiere ich mit
anhängern verschiedener politischer
parteien
da sollen leute die trump unterstützen
und social die tram passen miteinander
sprechen
so finden wir heraus was ihnen wirklich
wichtig ist denn bei abstimmungen fehlen
die leute ihre entscheidungen aus allen
möglichen gründen beim brad pitt ging es
für viele nicht um europa sondern darum
wie sie in ihrem privatleben darunter
leiden und unzufrieden sind zu filmen
sie schreiben an einer stelle das ein
gutes gespräch ein bisschen ist wie der
richtige umgang mit karten und denn die
karten spielen dann kriegen sie karten
wie kriege karten und normalerweise
tauschen wir irgendwie karten aus und
sie sagen das ist nicht das ende des
gesprächs sondern auch sie möchten
lästige kreieren irgendwie neue karten
also die erwachsenen sich sie sagen
irgendwo auch es geht darum nicht
einfach argumente auszutauschen sondern
die gedanken sollen sich umarmen
das sind alles wunderschöne bilder was
genau würde es heißen eine neue karte zu
erschaffen nehmen exit kontrabass sieht
wie können die argumente austauschen
ich kann lernen sie zu verstehen aber
irgendetwas scheinen sie darüber hinaus
zu wollen
tatsächlich seien völker war zuerst
einmal will ich dass die leute entdecken
wie schwierig und komplex jede normale
person ist
komplex die medizin konzentriert sich
auf kranke menschen
aber gesunde sind fast noch
komplizierter bei soviel im gehirn vor
sich geht
ich vergleiche es gern mit einem
antiquitätenladen der vollgestopft ist
mit allerlei krimskrams mit vorurteilen
aus früheren jahrhunderten mit ideen und
aberglauben wir alle sind so ich weiß
nicht was für eine sammlung von kam sie
in ihrem gehirn haben
es hängt davon ab was für bücher sie
gelesen haben andere als ich
wahrscheinlich
und wie sie von ihrem großvater
beeinflusst wurden und so weiter mit
jedem menschen denn wir kennen lernen
entdecken wir ein faszinierendes
geheimnis sie kennen zu lernen ist ein
großes vergnügen für mich denn bei jeder
begegnung entdecke ich eine ganze welt
vom duo xu die nicht ein system das und
sagt jeder mensch sei so oder so das
heißt die neue karte wäre so etwas wie
sie sehen die welt nach dem gespräch
anders
sie haben nicht nur den junk in meinem
hirn gesehen sondern sie sehen die welt
da draußen anders richtig und darum
nenne ich meine stiftung muse weil alle
poeten gerne ihre musen haben die sie
inspirieren
ich will sie nicht zu irgendetwas
passieren
ich halte ihnen keine predigt oder
versuche sie wie die vertreter der
achtsamkeit bewegung davon zu überzeugen
dass sie geheilt werden
ich bin kein therapeut ich glaube ganz
einfach es ist möglich dass irgend
welche gedanken die mir zufällig in den
sinn kommen bei ihnen anklang finden
zu ihrem raum straßen und somit nützlich
sind für sie so können die alle jeden
die musen einander sein dass sich auch
wiederum ein sehr sehr schönes bild gibt
es nie die situation dass sich in ein
gespräch langweilen uns zu geben müssen
das war jetzt kein musen gespräch kein
musen kuss sie sind selber schuld wenn
sie gelangweilt sind ja denn sie denken
nicht gründlich genug darüber nach warum
sie diese person langweilt spreche zum
beispiel mit leuten die sich für den
austritt aus der eu entschieden haben
interessanterweise haben sich sehr
intelligente leute dafür entstand und
einige arme kerl die meinten dadurch
würde die welt irgendwie besser
sie dachten sich nichts dabei sie hatten
genug von der bürokratie der eu es war
ihnen nicht bewusst dass diese nicht
schlimmer ist als jede andere bürokratie
warum waren sie so beschränkt sie
wussten zu wenig darüber
man lässt sich also auf ein gespräch ein
und lernt ständig voneinander
das meine ich mit neugierde wenn ihr
gehirn aktiv ist stößt es auf
interessante dinge
damit will ich sagen wir unterhalten uns
vom du zu tun
manchmal wird daraus freundschaft
manchmal heiraten leute die sich
zufällig begegnen
manchmal verbessert es auch die
atmosphäre
es ist zudem sehr nützlich für ausländer
die in unserem land fremd sind und sich
so kennenlernen kann
ich lernte viel von mördern die ich in
solchen gesprächen kennenlernen
sie erweisen sich als nette menschen
warum haben sie einen mord begangen weil
sie betrunken waren
sie kamen ins gefängnis und lernten dort
lesen und schreiben
ich habe noch was anderes mitgebracht
das spielt auch eine rolle in ihrem buch
nämlich der panda und sie sagen nämlich
so was wie wir sind keine pandabären und
pandabären haben ihrer meinung nach ein
problem die essen nämlich nur bambus das
stimmt nicht ganz hessen ja auch noch
ein paar andere pflanzen aber in erster
linie fressen sie bauen muss und sie
sagen wir sind keine pandabären die sind
nämlich großartig gewesen
wir können so ziemlich alles essen und
verdauen und eben auch ganz viele
gedanken verdauen und genau darum geht
es geht darum wie sie sagen unseren
geschmack ständig zu erweitern
das heißt das gute leben besteht für sie
darin immer wieder den geschmack zu
erweitern
heutzutage befassen sich viele mit der
frage wie man kreativ sein kann
man geht davon aus kreativität kommen
aus uns heraus und sei immer etwas
positives
sie können auch kreativ sein und etwas
böses tun
ich spreche daher lieber von erzeugung
stadt von kreativität
das heißt wenn ein mann und eine frau
sich begegnen dann entsteht vielleicht
ein kind und dieses kind ist sicher
anders aus die eltern immer es ist
anders als erwartet hat früher
versuchten die eltern ihre kinder so zu
formen wie sie es für richtig hielten
und sie scheiterten
meine idee der muse ist die
zusammenarbeit
anstatt vom individuum zu sprechen in
diesem modernen idealen oder der
alternative dem kollektiv spreche ich
über paare darunter verstehe ich nicht
nur liebespaar irgendwelche paare die
zusammen etwas produzieren indem sie
ideen voneinander übernehmen
sie stellen zum beispiel ihre fragen mit
viel humor in der meditation gibt es
keinen humor
[Gelächter]
der beliebte sein lachen ja aber sie
müssen verschiedene arten von humor
verstehen
das wollte ich ihnen meinen büchern
erforschen
ich begann damit in frankreich als ich
ein buch über frankreich schrieb ich
wollte den humor anbrennen
oder und andere menschen verstehen der
humor ist eine sehr komplizierte
angelegenheit
manchmal ist es ich manchmal satirisch
einfühlsam oder fantastisch wie in alice
im wunderland
doch der humor der mich am meisten
interessiert ist der humor der die
wahrheit auf deck der einen nicht auf
den arm nimmt
das haben humor und wahrheit miteinander
zu tun
könige hatten früher ihre namen diese
sagte dem könig was ihm keiner zu sagen
war nur der narr hatte die erlaubnis dem
könig die wahrheit zu erzählen
er sagte zum beispiel dieser minister
wickelt sie um den finger um etwas von
ihnen zu bekommen und das war die
wahrheit
es gibt wenige solche menschen denn es
ist sehr gefährlich ihrem vorgesetzten
oder leuten die sie kontrollieren können
offen die wahrheit zu sagen
alle waren dich du darfst niemanden
beleidigen
man soll zb keine religiösen themen
anschneiden um keine gläubigen zu
beleidigen so versuchen wir die wahrheit
zu verschleiern
[Musik]
für mich ist die wahrheit an diamant ein
diamant hat verschiedene facetten im
lauf der zeit verstanden ist die
diamanten schleifer immer besser
möglichst viele dieser facetten heraus
zu schaffen und jede reflektiert das
licht anders
heute haben wir uns auf unterschiedliche
tätigkeiten spezialisiert und sehen
verschiedene facetten der wahrheit
mich interessiert wie sie die wahrheit
sehen wie alle menschen darüber denken
und dann versuche ich all das zu ordnen
ich glaube wenn wir zurückblicken auf
das gespräch mit fischer davidson er
glaubt unser leben wird besser und die
menschheit wird besser wenn wir
meditieren sie glauben unser leben und
menschheit vielleicht auch wird besser
wenn wir miteinander sprechen und vor
allem auch neugierig bleiben denn
lebendig sein ist alles ich danke ihnen
sehr für dieses gespräch
ich sage nicht dass es wird anders
lebendiger
sie entdecken wie das leben ist manchmal
ist es gut dann wieder schlecht es ist
eine mischung sie können es nicht besser
machen
lassen sie sich nicht täuschen ich bin
kein typ ist vielen dank für diese
präzisierung der oder selten danke dass
sie hier waren auch nächste woche geht's
uns lebendig sein wieder allen system
zwar boss spricht mit philipp felsch
über adorno marcuse und die vor der 68er
am 14 mai zeichnen wir wieder eine
sternstunde der nacht auf im zürcher
kaufleuten diesmal zum thema des bösen
keine böse sondern eine freundliche
einladung haben sie bei der aufzeichnung
live dabei zu sein karten gibt es auf
unserer website und jetzt gleich sehen
sie hier ein porträt des künstlers peter
palensky der unerschrocken gegen den
russischen machtapparats kämpft danke
für ihr interesse und eine gute woche
[Musik]